so our next talk is my fighters cradle a
bunch came by simulation for guarded
Turtles teams okay thank you much what I
would like to do in my talk is to bring
together two threats of research and
logic which have not been present in
this workshop so one is a logic of
dependence and independence which are
based on team semantics and I will
briefly explain what it is as a second
perhaps more well known guarded logics
and the PI simulation and what we aim at
is to study to bring this notion of
guardedness into this setting of team
semantics so we study notions of guarded
teams and by simulations for guarded
teams and we our main objective our
characterization serums is in the style
of fun Bentham serums that relate at one
side logics on girardi teams on the
other side in variants under these
appropriate notions of pi simulations in
this setting and at the same time gives
the translation between the setting of
team semantics to classical Tuscan
semantics which will be inside an
existential second-order logic in this
case so first let me recall what garden
logics are right it have been introduced
in the 90s by undercut and Bentham
anonymity and the idea is to restrict
familiar logic such as first-order logic
and fixed-point logic in such a way that
we always talk in Alsip formally only
about tuples or assignments that are
close together in the sense that they
coexist in some atomic facts for
instance an edge or a tuple in a large
relation so we call an assignment giving
values to variables X 1 to K in the
structure a scart it if there is some
atomic fact that covers all these value
of the assignment and from this we can
get guarded fragments of familiar logics
by restricting quantification just in
either by a semantic definition or a
syntactic one so to ensure that all the
free variable of the four billion are
our guarded right because garden is of
course definable by a formula that this
was really to write down or we can
explicitly gives the atomic formula that
defines guard and we relativize
quantification syntactically took a
hearted assignments and an important
point is that these guarded logics
preserve almost all the convenient
properties that modal logics
have and lift them to a much more
powerful setting and I would even say
that guardedness in some way explains
why modal logics are so good there are a
number of results these have been
obtained all of the ten or between ten
and fifteen years ago so the card
attracting the first order logic sits
between modal logic and first-order
logic and if you do the same thing for
fixed point logic you get something that
sits between the modal me calculus and
LFP and the code properties of these
guarded fragments can be summarized as
follows two satisfiability problems for
discarded logic is decidable the guarded
fragment of Tortola has a finite model
property I think it's even true for you
proved it right it also is true for said
for guarded fixed point logic okay
although of course that not so fine
another plot which is very easy to
okay but perhaps even more important
fact is that remodel property that every
satisfiable formula have a bottle of
small tree with so essentially up to
interpretation a tree and this paves the
way to automata theory attic methods for
for for working with these with these
formulae and also the model checking
problem is much simpler than for
first-order logic in general because
associated evaluation games have small
size due to guardedness so you have to
in a quantification you have to go out
to all elements but just those that
preserve the guardedness right and more
recently there have been a renewed
interest there are new extensions to
more powerful the variance of carted
logics so lose the guard and click or
did our old ideas but more recently this
fragment of guarded negation has been
introduced by by Bahrani sycophant and
kata for instance right so but the
general message that these are well
behaved tame fragments of logic that
have good bottle theoretic and
algorithmic properties now an important
tool to study such guarded logic is a
variant of pi simulation so it's now in
classical PI simulation you have a game
moving around single vertices of a graph
now you move around guard it assignments
in a similar way I won't define it
precisely this is not really important
here so but we have a notion of guarded
by simulation saying that a particular
assignment one structure is guarded by
similar to another assignment in another
structure right so two plus can have not
fixed length this may change during such
a process a particular can also consider
see empty tuple and say that the two
structures are by similar but it's the
same idea and with this idea we get from
style characterization serums in the
sense saying that cigar defragment the
first order logic is precisely as a
fragment of first-order logic is
invariant under by simulation and same
thing for a fixpoint fragment so guarded
fixed-point logic is a fragment of
second-order logic first of all where we
restrict quantifications to guarded
relations and then takes it by
simulation invariant fragment so this is
an analogue of the fun Bentham
characterization serum for modal logic
and this is an analogue of session a
value here each serum force a modal my
calculus question is can we get similar
result in team semantics but then we
should first know what team semantics is
team semantics has been introduced by
Wilfred arches and well the idea is that
a formula is not as in tarski semantics
evaluate against a single assignment
giving values to the variables but as
against a set of such assignments and
and a set of assignments with sustained
main of variable is called a team for
actually rather bad reasons but this is
how it is the original motivation was to
provide a model theoretic rust at the
game theoretic semantics for a
particular logic of of dependence
independence for any logic if' not
necessarily finite so structures can be
anything you can it infinite teams if it
teams you can get infinite teams yeah so
as the same a system is a formula true
in a structure in a given assignment for
a for a given team right and a
motivation for this is that when you
look at the penn state like this
variable is dependent from that or these
two variables are independent this
doesn't really make sense if you just
consider a single assignment you need
large amounts of data to make sense of
this and this large amount of data can
be for instance table or a team right
and
this team semantics is very important
innovation in my opinion go way far
beyond the original application and is
really the basis for the modern logics
of dependence and independence that go
back to yoke over an anon and the idea
is that what does it mean the formulas
we can come to that at least a bit right
I will not really define it but just
hint a bit so first of all we start at
the atomic level but in if you know
these classical ways of making sense of
dependence that it depends like Hank and
quantified logics then dependence or
independence or incense special
quantifiers those annotations of
quantifiers where does it know this is
an atomic statement right so considered
various notions of dependence as an
atomic statement on a team right and
there are many of them these are
supporters of the most important ones
and for this talk inclusion and
exclusion are the most important ones so
depends just would say say variables and
why our functional independence on the
variables X in the given team so any two
assignments as coincide on X will also
coincide on why this notation was chosen
by Yoko and so I mean database series
will recognize these things these are
variants of database dependencies that
have been studied a long time but not
say as an atomic statement on which you
would build a logic right so I have been
supportive so inclusion would say every
value that occurs for X is the team also
occurs as a value for y exclusion is
tool saying the values that X may take
and why may take are disjoint and
independence is bit more complicated I
will not go into it
so the idea is to combine such atoms
with a logical connectives and
quantifier to obtain full-fledged logics
for reasoning about dependence and
independence and these logics require
team semantics to keep track can you
give a word about intuitively what
dependent and it means why they're like
dependence just is a very nice to say it
says that that if you consider a table
right so the columns are Saval use that
you have for what variables as the rows
are some particular assignments now
dependence means whenever in two
assignments coincide in the value for x
since must also coin sign is a value for
Y which means there is a function giving
you the value survived from the values
for X so function independent says
that's a values of occur together in all
possible combinations so since if you
know the team and I tell you what's a
value for x is for a particular sign we
have known nothing whatsoever about the
value of y all values are still possible
atomic level is the same thing
precisely so now if you add connectives
and quantifiers you get logic like
dependence logic independence logic
inclusion logic and so on get the right
variety of logic and they all require
team semantics so question is what
precisely does it mean that the formula
holds in a structure for a given team
but I will not explain you in this talk
right go to your covalence talk if you
next week if you're still here or the
folks on the talk in
the logic colloquium and in fact they
give me some more of a basic idea and
it's an important observation if you if
you just have first-order logic but
didn't add any dependents atoms then
this doesn't give something that is
really significantly new it just has a
flatness property which means that the
formula is true for a team if it is true
for all individual assignments in the
team of course this immediately breaks
down when you add these dependents atoms
and in the presence of non-flat
dependencies
this gives second-order features to to
first-order syntax in a sense right and
the most interesting case is in fact
this function because it's a disjunction
splits the team right if you say even
here right if you say either fee or C is
true in the team X you actually splits a
set of assignments into those that
satisfy Z and Toaster satisfy P so this
already includes introduces a
second-order feature and quantifiers do
as well and the consequence for instance
is that extremely simple formula can
express complicated properties 3sat can
be expressed by just a disjunction of
three dependence atoms two of which are
the same and with an inclusion atom you
can express ill-founded nice does the
existence of an infinite ascending chain
by a very very simple formula and so
unexpected things appear to understand
these unexpected things better we can
use a translation to tarski semantics so
we can a formula in a logic with team
semantics can be translated into an
existential second-order sentence that
takes the team as an additional relation
right team can be represented by a table
that is a relation
so a formula Waseem semantics is
translated into a sentence in Tarquin
semantics and this sentence will be an
existential second-order logic so we can
say well to understand the expressive
power of a logic with team semantics we
have to identify the right fragment of
Sigma 1 1 2 which it corresponds in that
sense and ok so and so results that are
known say well if you just have
exclusions or dependents then this
coincide with a fragment of Sigma 1 1
that is downwards closed in the sense
that's a predicate for the team appears
only negatively which also means if as
form is true for a team then it is also
true for all its sub teams if you add
either
inclusion and exclusion Bo's or if you
add independence then you gets a full
power of Sigma 1 1 so in particular on
finite structures you can express all NP
properties of teams and something very
interesting appears if you just add
inclusion logic that's just an inclusion
statements then ask Ali Ali and he'll
approve what you get is a fragment of
least fixed-point logic that uses only
greatest fixed point that uses them only
positively but by Neil a mermans result
we know that on finite structures this
is the full list fixed point logic so an
auto-fire structures in particular
inclusion dot recaps polynomial time and
it is captures at least letter P on
final structures without order but
writing for infinite structure you can't
capture full LFP I mean if full and if P
is no longer in Sigma no one even its
leaves in the Delta bond to fragment
right and this extends when you add
counting all right so we also get a
fixed a characterization or fix but
logic was counting in this sense so we
want to bring these two teams we have
very little time so the idea is to have
also a guarded notion of team and we
just say all assignments in it are guard
it and then you want normative define a
fragment of a guarded fragment of
first-order logic for teams we
restrict Samantha definition
semantically so that all operators just
talk only about Garda teams or we can do
it syntactically in the same way as one
did in the classical setting restrict
quantification relativized
quantification by a formula that says
everything is guarded right so it's no
problem to define a guarded fragment of
first order logic in teams but the
notion of by simulation becomes delicate
there are actually two notions of by
simulation so we can say that two teams
XY are by similar if they contain
contains the same guarded by simulation
types then we have an assignment s in
one team then you must have a by similar
assignment is the other team and vice
versa but there is not a possibility you
can say well we now look at this team as
an additional relation an expanse
structure currently and look whether
these expanded structure are by similar
and this is of course stronger it's a
more restrictive notion so when you're
by similar isn't strong since you're by
similar in the weak sense so if you are
invariant under the weak since your
invariant on there's a strong sense and
the converse is not true and in fact one
thing that witnesses are inclusions and
exclusions they are invariant in the
strong sense but not in the weak one and
because he considers in this way so we
have here two structures and when he
takes your side with a be in one and
co-signed a PI prime B prime then these
are by similar you can do precisely the
same things in two structures when you
move these edges around and also the
other pair of red edges BC and P prime P
double prime Z prime are by similar
hence when we take the teams that
combine this then say R by similar in
the weak sense because it contains the
same by simulation type but of course
they are not by similar in the strong
sense you can go from a red edge to
another red edge and you can't do here
right
but let me notice that you see the
exclusion Adam saying sources and
targets are disjoint this is true and B
but is not true in a so it's not
invariant under system notion of I'm the
weak notion of by similarity right they
are weakly by similar but one satisfies
the exclusion adamant the other one does
not and an identical argument shows this
for for inclusion as well but on the
other hand if we work this expanded
structure so we can use this predicate
for the team to guard our assignments
then we can easily define inclusion and
exclusion so they are invariant under
this as a notion of of by similarity but
an interesting thing is that with this
Junction this is no longer compatible so
also see individual exclusion atoms are
invariant under strong by simulation see
that this Junction is not and this can
you see by classical method of finite
model Theory if you take sufficiently if
you take cycles then each side each edge
in a cycle is by similar to each other
edge right but to split the cycle so
that you cover the entire one in an
inclusion respective matter is only
possible if the cycle has even lengths
and so with this Junction you could
separate sites of even lengths from
cycles of all links it was break by
similarity
okay now characterization serums what we
actually want right so here is a
characterization serum and it relates
many thing with each other so what is
green are always logics in classic
guitar skew semantics and for this blue
are logics in team semantics so what the
characterization serum says is that in
team semantics it's a fragment or
first-order logic that is invariant
under guarded by simulation is
equivalent to the guarded fragment
defining either syntactically
semantically this is not important but
it also corresponds to dough set of X
those sentences of X's tend to second
order logic that you can write in this
form so just saying every assignment in
X satisfies V where's the predicate for
the team does no longer occur in X so
just a flat this property expressed such
that this formula is in the guarded
fragment or you take it to be an
arbitrary formula and you take only C by
simulation invariant part so we have
since since many characterization serums
put into one giving all the same
formalism but now notice that these are
all described properties of teams that
are guarded horizontally this needs a
meaning that every individual assignment
is guarded what they are in first order
logic so it's downwards closed right and
there is also a stronger idea where you
do not consider the properties defined
that's why can't we start from what is
definable in first order logic of the
tarski side right so you look what is
definable in first order logic wizard at
least to predict 14 but without this
restriction how it occurs can occurred
in arbitrary way but it has to be
invariant under guarded by simulation so
of course you don't have down--which
closure anymore you can use this
predicate digs next anyway so to get a
corresponding thing on the other side
you have to do something to break this
downwards close it what what we have to
add is classical negation right
previously we had negation only on the
atomic level now you have classical
negation that you can really negate on
the entire level of the team but then
you get a similar characterizations here
and I should say the proofs very much
literally lie I have it on the previous
slide I didn't tell you on the basically
measures that have been
refined and developed by martin otto - -
got to bring down do self that you can
reason basically with founded quantify
rank to prove such results now it is
tempting to assume that you can add a
further thing that just take cigar
defragment wastes additional predicates
4x8 tarski semantic but this does not
work but this is only in variant in the
are the strong by simulation and not
under weak by simulation there's a
question arise is of course ours are
also characterization serums for this
stronger notion of by simulation and it
turns out that on the first order level
this doesn't bring anything different
about this this is not the true effect
in general it and it relies crucially on
the fact that that first order logic had
only express flat properties in sense
that it something holds for a team if it
holds for every individual assignment in
the team and if you don't have this then
the notions are different in fact this
is very interesting when we look at it
on the level of fixed point logic
because so this is just guarded fixed
point logic in the sense used used in
the classical setting and series a
characterization serum that is known for
that right we have a characterization
serum for god fixed point logic under by
simulation and when we take understands
the predicate as a team we're just in
the classical setting right so know we
know that a fixed point fixed point
logic is closely related to inclusion
logic so can we get a similar
characterization serum here and well in
a sense we have it to some extent right
it is not really completed in the sense
we have we know that what is invariant
invariant part of inclusion logic
is contained in in guarded fixed-point
logic with a precise characterization
but we don't really know yet whether we
have here an equivalence so as an
Outlook of course this notion this
notion of car the teams is just one way
how one come to fine guard the team's
what we did regard it's the teams
horizontally every assignment has to be
consist is a tuple that leads close
together we could also also look at the
columns so look at the set of all values
for one particular variable and say that
that's it has to be guarded covered in
some way it is perhaps not as natural
anymore to just guard it by the atomic
facts of the structure so we can look
any cyst in that would guard this let's
say given guarding hydrograph that would
cover this and this also has natural
motivation so if you understand a column
as a set of values that you observe for
in a particular measurement for instance
right it may make sense that these
values are in the sense close together
and only then make sense and if they
don't and there are there must be some
serious error with your measurement or
this value should be eliminated or
whatever right and so they are certainly
also motivation to consider vertical
notions of guardedness and and if I
appropriate logics for that so this is
not really difficult will contain such
vertically guarded team semantics or
vertically guarded first-order logic but
we do not yet really understand the
expressive power of these it very much
depends on how you guard there are
extreme cases when you guard almost
nothing only Singleton's or where
everything is guarded and then you get
not surprisingly not not
something new then this will collapse to
classical cases but there are
intermediate cases where's the power of
these guards makes a complexity very
high can can get almost two full
first-order logic but at this point this
is more or less just an Outlook right so
we have a relatively good understanding
what happens when you look at a
horizontally guarded setting and sober
totally vertically guarded setting is
more an idea and promise I mean I mean
already so database Theory has
considered implications between various
form of dependencies on the atomic level
quite extensively in the 1980s Oh
fortune know a lot about this and I
think even there a number of problems
are in fact undecided right so of course
I mean with the same semantics I mean
things become not easier as they come up
we are it more complicated that you
reason a more complicated setting and
notions of dependence or independence
are are not so simple notions I'd say
are they can cause you lots of headaches
and so I wouldn't expect that something
in this direction is
clothes right then a similar question
that I mean not having thought about
these teens it's odd so it takes me a
while to understand it I'm just probably
I want to you know if you could share a
little more intuition if when it's
really nice to have a team in one you
want it and the other is you know
because these come so straight from
tendencies maybe there's a place for and
David's theory whether nice notions can
be easier to say that way small piece
that would be actually let's say see
some motivation for this really good as
a been okay launches of dependence and
independence have been studied for a
long time but they haven't really come
to the mainstream of logic I would
really say right so hope I mean of
course strong proponent of this logic
with team semantics has been yoke over
annalen and his goal was really to set
up say a family of logics for reasoning
of depends and independence as they
arise in in many different sciences that
dependence and independence are really
concept arise everywhere in science and
in statistics in yes in in economy and
so it's really it's not just a notion
that that is a notion of mathematics
it's a note that appears in physics in
in many sciences and I think one of his
main goal was really to to build more
bridges to other Sciences and have a
system for reasoning about dependencies
and in dependencies that that would go
across Sciences now I'm not sure
how far it is goes at how promising this
is but that is one of the goals right
let's say my motivation is we have other
than I find these logics very
interesting and nicely defined that
really says the methods that we have in
finite model theory and descriptive
complexity answer one can bring
something to understand the power of
these logics and what what the
properties really are and also what your
algorithmic possibilities applica a
priori you are in a setting of NP of
sigma11 and it's completely unclear what
are the fragments for which you can
actually do something right but I think
the message that we we have can offer
here something but and Saucony I'm not
so sure about see connections to
databases because dependencies are of
course important in databases but is it
so important for databases to have say
all these logical operators on top of
them to reason inside databases it's
this I don't really seen on the other
side I mean Fulton has a very
interesting connection to constraint
satisfaction problems of a particular
variant of dependence logic so I think
they are really interesting connections
partially or the quantifiers which are
not very amenable to use in logic I
think this approach you can can you also
because I want to ask is in database we
also embedded but it embedded multi
value dependencies are independents or
conditional independence atoms it's yeah
it's more or less
so there is a kind of mystery why scent
solvers work there's something
mechanical case which works so I wonder
where the guarded fragments can explain
at least I don't think that car did I
mean they say such Souls work 44 typical
instances and guarded guardedness is a
way to marry to make it work in every
case right to really identify a fragment
that so in a sense I think the approach
to car thickness is a completely a token
approach was so successful so in the
places where first order proved
ourselves can apply to any np-complete
problems they could could plea apply to
the setting as well I mean of course one
could I mean let's say I see no
immediate connection of course one one
could try to use sat solvers to deal
with with formulas in depends or
independence so maybe they're more
natural stuff for typical stuff I don't
know